one of the building stories that we are
continuing to follow
is the pivot
or at least the potential pivot that
specifically fox news is setting up on
the republican party and on the 2024
presidential election and that pivot is
as follows
if trump is the republican nominee in
2024
fox news wants access to him fox news
wants to be in the good graces of the
administration
period but
fox
probably prefers that it not be donald
trump who is the nominee and there's a
bunch of different reasons why we could
imagine that's the case one would be
that rupert murdoch the patriarch of fox
news and news corporation doesn't really
like trump that's one possibility
second is that trump is divisive among
the right and that's not particularly
good for fox news because you start to
have contingents of the right that like
the coverage fox news is doing and those
that don't and it's just unnecessarily
controversial um so fox news is setting
itself up with a sort of escape hatch
in case trump's the nominee they want to
be able to get back on the trump train
but they do seem at least in this early
stage sort of to be taking a step
towards somebody like ron desantis or
somebody else
the new reports at are that trump is
absolutely furious that fox news is
ignoring him
and giving so much attention to other
potential candidates according to a
report trump hasn't appeared on fox news
in 100 days
according to the new york times he'd
rather have negative coverage than to be
ignored altogether
trump has reportedly complained to aids
that sean hannity a longtime friend is
also overlooking him trump is not happy
instead of broadcasting a july 22 trump
rally in arizona fox news aired a laura
ingraham interview with ron desantis
a live broadcast of trump's events with
conservative event with conservatives in
washington earlier this week was ignored
by fox for a live speech by mike pence
according to the times which cited two
people who have spoken to trump trump is
angrier about being ignored than he
would be if fox were to cover him
negatively
trump has complained to sean hannity as
i mentioned according to several people
close to the fox corporation which
rupert murdoch owns
the moves to exclude trump are not a
coincidence
as business insider previously reported
fox news is inching towards a post-trump
era
trump and fox news had a falling out
when the network called arizona for
biden in 2020 fox defended the call
trump protested it trump then moved
towards appearing on newsmax and the one
america news network
since then insider reported that a
roster of fox hosts and contributors
have issued stern critiques of trump and
support for other potential republican
nominees in a recent opinion piece by
fox news contributor liz peake desantis
was touted as a cure for an ailing
america now there's one thing that's
absolutely true
ron desantis would be a much more
effective
and probably to the republican party
unifying figure than trump
desantis's politics are not that
different than trump's
but desantis's personality
is less
comically outrageous than donald trump's
and would probably not anger as many
republicans as donald trump did and
every report that we're getting business
insider um new york times reports last
week that we talked about is that it's
not by chance that this is going on last
week or maybe it was the week before i
aired a two-minute piece that fox did
with
random republican voters right
and it just so happened that almost
every one of those random republican
voters said i don't think trump should
run in 2024
and i really like ron desantis the way
those pieces are produced usually you
talk to way more people than you include
in the package
and then you decide what to include i'm
sure that they came across republicans
who a bunch of them who said trump
should run they chose not to include
that they are starting to spin a
narrative remember that fox news has not
actually abandoned him fox news would
prefer someone else
and they want to be well positioned if
someone else is the nominee to
immediately be in the good graces of
that individual but if trump is the
nominee they want to be able to get
access to him as well there's a very
kind of strange mix happening right now
of
cringy sucking up to trump
but also mentioning that there's lots of
republicans out there they're out there
in the ether who would prefer
somebody other than donald trump and
this shouldn't really come as a shock
because it's a repeat of 2016. in 2015
into 2016 fox did not like donald trump
they
were supporting other people
i believe it was ted cruz they were
pretty pretty uh positive on
until it became clear that trump was
going to be the nominee and then all of
a sudden they were tripping all over
themselves to brown nose
and to get in donald trump's good graces
in which they were for the vast majority
of trump's presidency so this is not a
new pattern but trump is reportedly
furious trump being furious can only
lead to hilarity and we'll be standing
by for that